let's go next to the 705 area code 705
can you hear me what's going on
yeah hey David can you hear me we can
hear you loud and clear
awesome perfect I just wanted to speak
Oh real quick on my name is Lyle and I'm
from Canada okay good awesome yeah I
just wanted to speak real quick about
miss Martha Raddatz um interview that
Kellyanne called me had yeah with my
believe it was yesterday or the day
before it was several days ago but yeah
I know the interview you're talking
about
yeah just unbelievable um her defense of
this Twitter beef that North Korea's Kim
jong-un whatever his name is with Trump
saying how how she wants to establish
peace so we want to establish peace so
he's do you think calling someone short
and staff is helpful
so now Kellyanne responds that was just
the president responding the way he does
to somebody who insulted him first right
right but liya that makes sense
he started it is there any kind of
morals we want to teach our children and
Trump didn't call him short and fat no
he said he could be calling him short
and fat but he's choosing not to be for
that level because he's not gonna stoop
to that level
yeah oh I would be if I were a parent
right now and I had kids who were old
enough to start gleaning a little bit of
what's going on I would really be having
a crisis in terms of how how do I deal
with this how do I talk to kids about
what's going on and explain to them that
these things aren't real talking about
grabbing by the [ __ ] by the president
that's not normal that's not this is not
supposed to be real life all the entire
I don't know what I would be doing while
it's pretty on record don't you think
the press like well obviously
realistically the president is Hadj
holds the most moral standard high holds
the most if you want to be a police
officer for example I had a know how it
works in the States but for example you
want to be a police officer in Canada
where I live in Ontario they're going to
check my background
meet you want to check my facebook
you're gonna want to check for example
the family I have if my brother is
friends or with a drug dealer for
example they may not want to be involved
with me now how can the President of the
United States hold all of these corrupt
individuals yeah it's yeah these values
and these morals and just speak the way
he does it yeah so wild to me it's mind
boggling but hey at least you live in
Canada at the end of the day so you've
got that going for you
we're not hearing man but hey if I feel
for you and Pat that's all alright
thanks very much for the call appreciate
it